Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool, towels, and camp laundry with a large capacity washer. And host and style with the fridge-serving craft ice, mini-craft ice, cube ice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US-only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more.
让每一次聚会都轻松惬意。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在全国家得宝（The Home Depot）选购 LG 等各大顶尖品牌的精选家电，最高可再省 1,000 美元。此外，还可享受免费送货服务。使用大容量洗衣机，轻松搞定泳池毛巾和露营换洗衣物。配备可制作方块冰、细碎冰以及精酿冰球和迷你精酿冰球的冰箱，让您待客聚会更有型。即日起至 6 月 3 日，快来家得宝选购特惠家电。优惠有效时间为 5 月 14 日至 6 月 3 日，仅限美国。购买 998 美元或以上的家电可享免费送货。
See Store Online for details. Our families can be our biggest source of love and support, but family members can also cause us grief, heartache, stress, and pain, sometimes more than almost anyone else can. When that happens, we might feel we have no choice but to cut ties. Psychologists who study family estrangement say that estrangement is far more common than many people realize. But stigma around the topic can keep people from reaching out for the help they need to call. hope with their family members, decide whether they want to reconcile, and figure out how to do it if that's what they wish. So how common is family estrangement? What are the most frequent reasons that it happens? If you're estranged from a family member, by your choice or theirs,
详情请参阅店内或线上信息。我们的家人可能是我们最大的爱与支持的来源，但家庭成员也可能带给我们悲伤、心痛、压力和痛苦，有时甚至超过其他任何人。当这种情况发生时，我们可能会觉得别无选择，只能切断联系。研究家庭疏离的心理学家表示，疏离现象比许多人意识到的要普遍得多。然而，围绕这个话题的污名化可能会让人不敢寻求所需的帮助，从而无法与家人重新建立希望，决定是否想要和解，并且如果那是他们的愿望，弄清楚该如何做到这一点。那么，家庭疏离有多普遍？导致这种情况发生的最常见原因是什么？如果你与某位家庭成员疏离了，无论是出于你的选择还是他们的选择，
how can you decide whether it makes sense to try to repair the relationship? Can therapy be helpful? And if so, what should you look for in a therapist? Is there a difference between estrangement between parents and children, between siblings, or between other family members. And why does the stigma around estrangement persist? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Lucy Blake, a developmental psychologist and senior lecturer in psychology
你该如何决定尝试修复这段关系是否有意义？心理治疗会有帮助吗？如果是的话，在寻找治疗师时你应该寻找什么？父母与子女之间、兄弟姐妹之间或其他家庭成员之间的疏离有什么区别吗？为什么围绕疏离的污名会一直存在？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是露西·布莱克博士（Dr. Lucy Blake），她是一名发展心理学家，也是英国
at the University of the West of England in the UK. She studies family estrangement and the ways in which a negative, distant or inactive relationship with a family member can affect people's lives. She's published dozens of academic studies and is author of the book, No Family is Perfect, a guide to embracing the messy reality. Dr. Blake, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. It's a pleasure to be here. How do you define estrangement in your work? Does it mean people who have fully caught off contact with a family member, Or can it be broader, say, someone who has very infrequent contact or just feels emotionally distant from someone in their family?
西英格兰大学（University of the West of England）心理学高级讲师。她研究家庭疏离，以及与家庭成员保持消极、疏远或不活跃的关系如何影响人们的生活。她发表了数十项学术研究，并著有《没有完美的家庭：拥抱混乱现实的指南》（No Family is Perfect, a guide to embracing the messy reality）一书。布莱克博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。在您的工作中，您是如何定义“疏离”的？这是否意味着与某位家庭成员完全切断了联系，或者它的范围可以更广，比如与某人联系非常不频繁，或者只是觉得与家里的某人在情感上很疏远？
I tend to take a broader approach when I'm thinking about what estrangement is. So I certainly have spoken with and heard the experiences of people who have no contact whatsoever and maybe haven't been in contact for decades. But I also hear from people who perhaps exchange cards at the holidays or see each other. the once or twice a year. And I've even spoken with people who identify with the feelings of estrangement and as being estranged from a family member when they're currently living with them as well. So I'm quite open to some of those complexities, but that can be difficult in a research context as well when we try and be precise about terms. How common is estrangement? Is there reliable research that has measured how many people are estranged from at least one member
在思考什么是疏离时，我倾向于采取更广泛的方法。因此，我当然与那些完全没有联系、甚至可能已经几十年没有联系的人交谈过，也听取了他们的经历。但我也会听到一些人的经历，他们可能在节假日互赠卡片，或者一年见上一两次面。我甚至和一些人交谈过，当他们目前正和某位家庭成员住在一起时，他们也会认同疏离的感觉，并觉得自己与该家庭成员疏离了。因此，我对其中的一些复杂性持相当开放的态度，但当我们在研究中试图对术语进行精确定义时，这可能会变得很困难。疏离有多普遍？是否有可靠的研究测量过有多少人与至少一位家庭成员
of their family. So I think in the past 10 years, we've seen more really high quality studies come out on this. So I'm thinking of studies where researchers have spoken to thousands of people and they've been interested in the quality of the relationship. So is it kind of distant and lacking in closeness and that frequency of contact? And when they look at both of those things together, we find, or certainly I was surprised by how high the rates were. So we've got some indication that it. It's one in four siblings who will experience a period of estrangement from a brother or sister and that it's around 20% of adults who will experience a period of estrangement from a father and around slightly lower at 9% who will experience estrangement from a mother.
处于疏离状态？因此我认为，在过去 10 年里，我们看到越来越多真正高质量的相关研究问世。所以我想到了那些研究，其中研究人员与数千人进行了交谈，并且他们对关系质量很感兴趣。比如，这种关系是否有点疏远、缺乏亲密感以及联系频率如何？当他们把这两件事结合起来看时，我们发现——或者说，至少我对比例之高感到惊讶。因此，有迹象表明，在兄弟姐妹中，四分之一的人会经历一段与兄弟姐妹疏离的时期；大约 20% 的成年人会经历一段与父亲疏离的时期；比例稍低，约有 9% 的人会经历与母亲疏离的时期。
And some of the data I'm drawing on there is kind of large-scale data from Germany and obviously some of these numbers are going to differ according to country and content. text, but I think they certainly open the door to appreciating estrangement isn't rare. This is a common experience. Do we know if there are actually cultural differences? Unfortunately, I think we're still in the early days of estrangement research. So the data I'm thinking of comes from the US mostly or Germany. Off the top of my head, I can't think of that kind of comparative data.
我所借鉴的一些数据来自德国的大规模数据，显然，其中一些数字会根据国家和内容的不同而有所差异。文本，但我认为它们确实为我们理解疏离并不罕见打开了大门。这是一种常见的经历。我们知道是否存在真正的文化差异吗？不幸的是，我认为我们仍处于疏离研究的早期阶段。因此，我脑海中想到的数据主要来自美国或德国。凭我的记忆，我想不出那种比较数据。
I still think we're learning about what the word estrangement means. to people. So it might be in some cultures and context. The word doesn't resonate. It doesn't have the same meaning as it might do in like a white Western context. So it's complicated and I think we have a lot to to find out still. Now I've seen some reporting and surveys that have found that family estrangement is on the rise. Do you think that's true? I mean, you're looking at the data. Does the data support this? I personally can't think of anything that supports it. I think it might be that we, are talking about estrangement a little bit more than we have done in previous decades. We certainly have more estrangement research than we have done ever before.
我依然认为我们仍在了解“疏离”这个词对人们意味着什么。因此，在某些文化和背景下，这个词可能不会引起共鸣。它不像在白人西方文化背景下那样具有相同的含义。所以情况很复杂，我认为我们还有很多东西需要去发现。现在，我看到一些报道和调查发现，家庭疏离呈上升趋势。你认为这是真的吗？我的意思是，你正在研究数据。数据支持这一点吗？我个人想不出任何支持这一说法的依据。这可能是因为我们谈论疏离的频率比过去几十年要多一些。我们目前拥有的疏离研究确实比以往任何时候都要多。
And it might be that people are seeking out therapy or support or help for estrangement more than they have before. But I'm not sure that necessarily means it's on the rise. I think I personally wouldn't agree with that statement. But I understand that it's. It's a way of thinking about estrangement that also frames it as being inherently quite negative. Like the language of epidemic or pandemic is often used. And I think that framing can be quite difficult sometimes as well.
而且人们可能是比以前更多地寻求心理治疗、支持或帮助来应对疏离。但这并不一定意味着它在上升。我想我个人不会同意这种说法。但我理解，这是一种看待疏离的方式，它也将疏离本质上塑造成一种非常消极的事情。比如人们经常使用流行病或大流行这样的词汇。我认为这种框架有时也会带来很大的困扰。
Because although it can be extremely painful and difficult for people, there are ways in which estrangement ensures people's safety and well-being. So I think the framing of estrangement is really important. What are some of the most common reasons that estrangement happens? Again, we're still learning about this, but common causes that I found in my own research are that of emotional abuse. So people feeling that there is a quality in the relationship that isn't safe. And that might be referring to acts in the relationship like, you know, calling somebody names
因为尽管它对人们来说可能是极其痛苦和困难的，但在某些方面，疏离也确保了人们的安全和福祉。因此，我认为如何看待和界定疏离真的非常重要。导致疏离发生的最常见原因有哪些？同样，我们仍在了解这一点，但在我自己的研究中发现的常见原因是情感虐待。因此，人们觉得这种关系中存在某种不安全的特质。这可能指的是关系中的一些行为，比如，你知道的，辱骂某人，
or kind of teasing someone, bullying someone, or that might be that the relationship just doesn't have a quality of closeness or safety in it. And I think other common causes that we know about are divorce. So really common family experiences rather than rare things that happen in families. They're the everyday things that happen. So if a parent is going through a divorce, it might be that children feel drawn into taking aside. or it might be that relationships weaken over time, especially we find between fathers and their adult children.
或者嘲笑某人、欺凌某人，或者可能仅仅意味着这种关系本身缺乏亲密感或安全感。我们所知的其他常见原因还包括离婚。这些是家庭中发生的非常普遍的经历，而不是什么稀奇的事，而是每天都在发生的事情。因此，如果父母正在经历离婚，孩子们可能会觉得被卷入其中去站队；或者随着时间推移，关系可能会减弱，我们发现这种情况尤其容易发生在父亲与成年子女之间。
And there'll be some variation there, obviously depending on how close those relationships were before the divorce and all different kinds of factors like that. Other causes might be about not having the same values as a family member. So feeling that your family member doesn't have the same way of thinking about important issues, perhaps like gender or sexuality or religion. And sometimes those values can drive people into a distant relationship or into estrangement. So that's certainly not all of the reasons.
这其中会有所不同，显然取决于离婚前这些关系的亲密程度以及所有诸如此类的各种因素。其他原因可能涉及与家庭成员没有相同的价值观。比如觉得你的家庭成员对重要议题没有相同的看法，可能类似于性别、性取向或宗教信仰。有时，这些价值观差异会导致人们关系疏远或产生疏离。所以这当然不是全部的原因。
There are all sorts of different pathways to estrangement. But I think those are some of the most common ones. Do these rifts usually build slowly over time? or are they more often precipitated by some kind of a dramatic event? So again, we're quite early in the research, but I'm thinking of some excellent studies by Christina Sharp in the US, who has spoken to adults who identify as having a negative relationship with a parent and they've sought distance because of that.
通往疏离的途径有各种各样。但我认为这些是最常见的一些原因。这些裂痕通常是随着时间慢慢积累的，还是更经常由某种戏剧性事件引发的？同样，我们的研究还处于早期阶段，但我想到了美国克里斯蒂娜·夏普（Christina Sharp）的一些优秀研究，她曾与那些自认为与父母关系消极并因此寻求距离的成年人进行过交谈。
And in her studies, the adults that she's spoken to describe it as a stranger. typically building over time. So there might be an event, which is like the straw that breaks the camels back, but actually the roots of the estrangement often have this longer lasting history to them. Well, let's talk about one of the most difficult questions that estrangement brings up. How can a person know whether they should try to repair a fractured family relationship or whether it's better for their mental health and well-being just to stay out of contact? I think it's going to be really individual how people approach that question of whether to seek
在她的研究中，与她交谈的成年人将其描述为通常是随着时间推移而逐渐加深的疏离。可能确实有一个事件，就像压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，但实际上疏离的根源通常有着更长久的历史背景。好吧，让我们来谈谈疏离带来的最困难的问题之一。一个人如何才能知道自己是应该尝试修复破裂的家庭关系，还是为了自己的心理健康和福祉最好还是保持断联？我认为，对于是否寻求接触、尝试重聚，还是维持疏离状态，或者一开始就建立疏离，人们如何处理这个问题将是非常个性化的。
contact or try and reunite or whether to maintain estrangement or establish estrangement in the first place. I think that it's really hard to kind of have an opinion on what you think is best unless you are that person in that relationship. People will have all sorts of different lives and they will have different elements of support they can draw on or that isn't available to them. So I think it's a really good question, but it's a really hard one that I don't have an answer to and that I really think that is for each individual to decide for themselves. Now, you've done some research on how therapy can be useful in sorting through issues like this. How can therapy help and what should people look for in a therapist if this is the question
除非你就是关系中的那个人，否则很难对你认为什么是最好的事情发表意见。每个人的生活各不相同，他们可以利用的支持因素也各不相同，或者说这些支持对他们来说并不适用。所以我觉得这是一个很好的问题，但也是一个我没有答案的难题，我真的认为这需要每个人自己去决定。现在，您已经做了一些关于心理治疗如何有助于理清此类问题的研究。心理治疗能提供怎样的帮助，如果人们正试图处理这个问题，他们在寻找治疗师时应该注意什么？
that they're trying to deal with. I've spoken with people who found therapy to be very helpful, and there's some conditions that are in place when it's a really helpful avenue of support. And the key is really the nature of that relationship with the therapist. So when therapy can be really helpful, it has those qualities of warmth and validation, and often those qualities can be missing in. estranged family relationships so they can be really restorative within a therapeutic context. I think people can also find therapy very helpful if their therapist has an understanding of
我和一些人交谈过，他们发现心理治疗非常有帮助，而且当心理治疗成为真正有帮助的支持途径时，是有一些前提条件的。其中的关键其实在于与治疗师的关系性质。因此，当心理治疗能发挥真正作用时，它就具备温暖和确认的特质，而这些特质在疏离的家庭关系中往往是缺失的，因此它们在心理治疗的语境中可以起到很好的修复作用。我认为，如果治疗师对疏离有理解，人们也会发现心理治疗非常有帮助。
estrangement. So some appreciation that it's rarely one relationship that's affected when there's an estrangement. There's usually this ripple effect where it can impact relationships with siblings or nieces and nephews or aunts and uncles. It can also be helpful when therapists really understand some of those causes that I was talking about, like abuse in a family relationship, or mental health issues and challenges that can affect family relationships as well. So those are some of the conditions, I think, of growth that can be really helpful for seeking therapy. And then I've also heard from people that have found therapy to be very unhelpful. And that's typically when that relationship lacks those important qualities of women's
也就是说，要认识到当出现疏离时，很少只有一种关系受到影响。通常会产生连锁反应，影响到与兄弟姐妹、侄子侄女或叔伯阿姨的关系。如果治疗师真正理解我刚才谈到的一些原因，比如家庭关系中的虐待，或者影响家庭关系的心理健康问题和挑战，那也会很有帮助。因此，我认为这些是寻求心理治疗时能够带来成效的一些重要条件。不过，我也听到有人说他们觉得心理治疗毫无帮助。这通常发生在那种关系缺乏那些重要的温暖和确认特质的时候，
validation or when they feel like a therapist doesn't have that understanding of just the enormous impact that estrangement can have on people's lives and their well-being and that often estrangement can feel like a significant loss and really appreciating the grief and bereavement that happens often when there is an experience of estrangement. So I think it can be a really helpful, it can be a really helpful avenue of support for some, and we're still really learning about what it is that's helpful and not at this point. Is there a big difference between estrangements that involve parents and children and those between siblings, or are the underlying emotions that people are dealing with essentially the same? There's some ways in which there's
或者当他们觉得治疗师根本无法理解疏离会对人们的生活和福祉造成巨大影响时，也无法理解疏离往往会让人觉得是一种重大的失落，并且没有真正体会到在经历疏离时常常伴随的悲伤与哀痛。因此，我认为对某些人来说，这可以是一个非常有帮助的支持途径，但在现阶段，我们仍在摸索究竟是什么在发挥作用，什么没有作用。父母与子女之间的疏离与兄弟姐妹之间的疏离有很大区别吗？还是说人们内心处理的基本情感本质上是一样的？在某些方面，它们确实有
similarities, I think, particularly in terms of the significant loss that can happen with estrangement, the feelings of not even just loss of the relationship itself, but loss of what that family relationship could be or should be. There's some ways in which I think it's different as well. So I think with siblings, we tend to have fewer expectations about what that relationship should ideally look like. Regular contact is something I think. think that we assume parents and adult children should have in their relationship. And it's a little bit more open for sibling relationships. I think as well the causes can sometimes be different. So with the sibling relationship, it might be those events later in adulthood that
相似之处，我认为，特别是在疏离所带来的重大失落感方面，这种失落不仅是对关系本身的失落，还包括对家庭关系本可以成为或应该成为什么样的失落。在某些方面，我也认为它们是不同的。因此，我认为对于兄弟姐妹，我们对这种关系的理想状态通常抱有较少的期望。我认为，我们觉得父母和成年子女在他们的关系中应该保持常规联系。而兄弟姐妹的关系则更开放一些。我也认为，原因有时会有所不同。对于兄弟姐妹关系来说，可能是成年后期的那些事件真正引发了疏离。
really spark the estrangement. So it might be issues relating to how to handle a parent being ill requiring care or a parent passing, or it might be issues related to inheritance that can really kind of drive siblings apart from one another and damage their relationship. So sometimes I think the causes of the estrangement are different. But there are ways in which that feeling, that feeling of loss, that feeling of perhaps uncertainty of not knowing if there'll be a reunion, that can feel the same. in some way, I think. You said this place was steps from the water.
因此，这可能涉及如何处理父母生病需要照顾或父母离世的问题，或者可能涉及与遗产继承相关的问题，这些问题确实会把兄弟姐妹推向对立面并损害他们的关系。所以有时我认为疏离的原因是不同的。但在某种程度上，那种感觉、失落感、对是否会重聚的不确定感，在某种程度上可能会是一样的。你不是说这里离水面只有几步之遥吗？
We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now.
我们只是还没找到那些台阶罢了。我们省了多少？够了。够去寻找自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水面仅数步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。
Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. for this day. Now, if you've been cut off and you want to reconnect, what are some of the ways to approach the person who cut you off? I think this is something that we have less data on as researchers. We're just in the last 10 years, we've seen this gross of studies in figuring out what estrangement is, what causes it, how it impacts people's lives. But I think we know less
在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿App上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱，而不是惊喜。您住哪里很重要。度过这一天。现在，如果你被切断了联系，而你想重新建立联系，有哪些方法可以接近那个切断你联系的人？我认为作为研究人员，我们在这方面的数据较少。我们在过去 10 年里才看到研究的大幅增长，以弄清楚什么是疏离、它的起因是什么、它如何影响人们的生活。但我想我们知道得更少
at this point in terms of published data about what are the conditions for reunion and what helps family members get back in contact again and become closer again. So here I think listening to people's personal experiences can be very helpful. I think support groups can be really helpful for people in this situation of just hearing what has worked for other people. But in terms of published research data, I think we know less. And you mentioned support groups. I understand that there are support groups on both sides,
就目前已发表的数据而言，关于重聚的条件是什么，以及是什么帮助家庭成员重新取得联系并再次变得亲密，我们所知有限。所以在这里，我认为倾听个人的经历会非常有帮助。我认为支持小组对于处在这种情境中的人来说会非常有帮助，可以让他们听听对其他人有效的方法。但就已发表的研究数据而言，我认为我们所知较少。你刚才提到了支持小组。据我所了解，双方都有支持小组，
either for the people who are estranged or the people who did the cutting off. That's right. There are a number of support groups available for parents estranged from adult children. Adult children are strange from parents and also people estranged from siblings. and those can be really helpful places in that you'll get to meet people who get it, who you don't have to kind of really explain necessarily your situation from scratch because someone's going to have some idea, not a full idea, but someone will have some idea of what your experience is like.
无论是为了那些被疏离的人，还是为了那些主动切断联系的人。没错。有许多支持小组可供选择，包括与成年子女疏离的父母、与父母疏离的成年子女，以及与兄弟姐妹疏离的人。这些地方真的很有帮助，因为你会遇到那些“感同身受”的人，你不必从头到尾真正解释你的处境，因为总会有人对你的经历有所了解，虽说不一定是全部了解，但总会有人理解你的感受。
And we've done some work in the UK at looking at support groups and find that they can be really helpful for some people in feeling less alone. And just the ability to connect with someone else who gets it can be really valuable. Say you did the severing and a family member makes overtures to you. Is there any research that tells you how you should respond? And I'm just wondering, should you try to talk out the reasons for the breakup? Or is it better just to move on and not dwell on the past? That's a great question.
我们在英国做了一些关于支持小组的研究，发现它们对某些人很有帮助，能让他们觉得不那么孤单。而且能够与另一个真正理解的人建立联系，其价值是非常巨大的。假设你主动切断了联系，而一位家庭成员向你伸出了橄榄枝。有没有任何研究告诉你应该如何回应？我只是在想，你应该试着把决裂的原因谈清楚吗？还是直接向前看、不要纠结于过去会更好？这是一个很好的问题。
And I think it's when we have very little published research data on. So I think that's really going to depend on the individual and their context, their circumstances, and it's going to depend on that estranged relationship as well and the kind of causes of the estrangement and how it's impact their lives. So I think that's going to be a very individual response to that question. So I'm just wondering what got you interested in this topic for research and have you experienced estrangement? And in your family, I mean, a lot of psychologists tell me, it's not research, it's me search. Yeah, this is a really popular question that I'm asked a lot. And I would say my family tree is quite complex.
我认为我们在这方面几乎没有什么已发表的研究数据。因此，这真的要取决于个人及其背景、他们的环境，也将取决于那种疏离的关系本身以及疏离的原因和它对他们生活的影响。所以我觉得对于这个问题，每个人都会有非常个性化的回应。我只是在想，是什么让你对这个研究课题感兴趣？你经历过疏离吗？在你的家庭里，我是说，很多心理学家告诉我，这不是研究，这是“自我搜寻”。是的，这是一个非常受欢迎的问题，我经常被问到。我想说我的家谱相当复杂。
It's a real mixed bag. So there are some relationships that are very close and supportive. And somewhere there's a lot of conflict and somewhere there's estrangement as well. So there certainly is estrangement in a lot of the branches of my family tree. and I think 10 years ago, when I was doing family research, I felt quite frustrated and quite confused. Like, why aren't I reading about families that look and feel like my own? Like, why is this so hidden? And 10 years ago, we really didn't have much in the way of published research on this topic. So it's really exciting now that 10 years later, we've got so much more to draw on. And obviously,
这是一个真正的混合体。因此，有些关系非常亲密和支持。有些关系则存在很多冲突，还有一些关系存在疏离。所以我的家谱的很多分支中确实存在疏离。而且我认为10年前，当我做家庭研究时，我感到相当沮丧和困惑。比如，为什么我读不到那些看起来和感觉起来像我自己的家庭？为什么这被隐藏得这么深？10年前，我们在该主题上确实没有多少已发表的研究。所以现在10年后，我们有如此多的资料可以借鉴，这真的令人兴奋。显然，
I found that what I've learned in my own research has been kind of a huge comfort to me personally, because where I used to think that my family was very different from other people's families and less than other people's families, I now have this understanding, actually, the estrangements in my family tree make my family much more like other people's families. And I've found that to be a big comfort. So what do you do if you're a family member in the middle? Say your parent is estranged from one of your siblings or your children don't talk to each other. What's your advice for people in that situation? I think that's a difficult one that we don't have too much data on as a researcher.
我发现我在自己的研究所学到的东西对我自己来说是一个巨大的慰藉，因为过去我认为我的家庭与别人的家庭非常不同，不如别人的家庭，而现在我明白了，实际上，我家谱中的疏离让我的家庭更像是其他人的家庭。我发现这是一种巨大的慰藉。如果你是一个处于中间地位的家庭成员，你该怎么办？比如说，你的父母与你的某个兄弟姐妹疏离了，或者你的孩子不和。对于处于这种境地的人，你有什么建议？我认为这是一个难题，作为研究人员，我们并没有太多相关的数据。
But I think that really some self-compassion would be helpful here as well as to anybody at any point who is. experiencing estrangement, whether it's their own or that of their family member. Families are a place where we often expect loyalty. So when there is an estrangement between, say, parents and a sibling, it's difficult over time to maintain a position where you're kind of in the middle or supportive of both parties. Over time, people are often expecting you to be loyal to one member over another. So I feel like we know that that can be one of the difficulties
但我认为，在这里对自己多一些同情心会很有帮助，对于任何在任何时候经历疏离的人来说也是如此，无论是他们自己的疏离还是他们家庭成员的疏离。家庭往往是一个我们期望忠诚的地方。因此，当父母与兄弟姐妹之间存在疏离时，随着时间的推移，要维持一种居中或对双方都支持的立场是很困难的。随着时间的推移，人们往往期望你对某一个成员比对另一个成员更忠诚。所以我觉得我们知道这可能是困难之一，
and also a feeling of loss as well, loss of a family unit and how it used to function. And so at this point in terms of thinking how people can cope with that, perhaps there's some solace in knowing that it's so common and that there will be millions of other people in your same situation. And perhaps there's also some comfort to be found as well. in finding a kind of voice for navigating through it because we can only be responsible for our own part in family relationships. So we can't control or shape or dictate the quality of other
同时也会有一种失落感，对家庭单元及其过去运作方式的失落。因此，在思考人们如何应对这一点时，也许知道这种情况非常普遍，并且有数百万其他人和你处于相同的处境，这会带来一些慰藉。也许在寻找一种声音来度过这一关时，也能找到一些安慰，因为我们只能对自己在家庭关系中所扮演的角色负责。因此，我们无法控制、塑造或左右其他人的家庭关系的质量。所以我想责任的一个方面是值得思考的，以及我们如何才能真正只对关系中自己的一端负责。为什么你认为围绕疏离的想法有这么多的污名？我的意思是，我们都会和朋友分手，浪漫关系会变坏。如果你想用这个词的话，我们的生活中存在着各种各样的疏离。但出于某种原因，家庭疏离对许多人来说是一个深不见底的秘密。确实如此。在大多数社会中，我认为即使不是全部，家庭也被奉上神坛。我们真的把家庭理想化了。因此，如果我们想到我们在节假日看到的或在社交媒体上看到的画面，通常都是家庭成员聚在一起，
people's family relationships. So I think there's probably an aspect of responsibility that it's helpful to think about and how we can only really be responsible for our own side of a relationship. Why do you think there is so much stigma around the idea of estrangement? I mean, we all sort of break up with friends, romances go awry. There's all kinds of estrangement, if you want to use that term, in our lives. But for some reason, family estrangement is a deep, dark secret for a lot of people. It absolutely is. In most societies, I think, if not all, family is on a pedestal. We really idealize family. So if we think of the images that we see at the holidays or that we see on social media, it's usually family members together,
穿着配套的睡房、堆满食物的大餐桌、一起过节、共享天光。如果我们想到政治演讲，政客们如何谈论家庭、婚姻或为人父母，你知道的，它确实被提升得如此之高，以至于在那种意义上它不可能真实存在。任何我们崇拜并供奉在神坛上的东西都会跌落下来。而且我认为尤其是对父母而言，
matching pajamas, kind of big dinner tables piled high with food, holidays together, time together. If we think of political speeches, how politicians speak about the family or about marriage and parenthood, you know, it really is, it's elevated so high that it can't really be real in that sense. Like anything that we worship and put up on that pedestal is going to come down. And I think that for parents especially,
我认为为人父母是人们生活中非常核心的身份认同。当这种身份受到挑战，当这种关系变得疏离时，去应对“我是谁”这个问题会变得非常困难，而且身份认同的问题当然也与所有卷入疏离的人息息相关，
I think parenthood is such a central identity to people's lives. And when that identity is challenged, when that relationship becomes estranged, it can be really difficult to navigate that question of who am I? and issues of identity are also really relevant, of course, for everyone involved in estrangement,
比如儿子和女儿、兄弟姐妹。你知道的，当这些关系疏远或疏离时，我们如何看待自己？所以我想这就是为什么它如此难以启齿的部分原因，因为我们只是觉得它本该完全不同。我认为疏离是一个如此迷人的研究领域，正是因为这个原因，因为它真正挑战了“家庭是什么样子的？”
like sons and daughters, brothers and sisters. You know, how do we think about ourselves when these relationships are distant or estranged? So I think that's some of the reason why it's so difficult to talk about is that we just think it should be so different. And I think estrangement is such a fact fascinating field of study for that reason because it really challenges, well, what is family
家庭究竟是什么样的，而不是它们可以是什么样的或它们应该是什么样的。我想这很大程度上是由一种恐惧驱动的，人们会看着你，然后说，你一定是个糟糕的父母，或者你是个烂透了的兄弟姐妹，这就是为什么你们不再联系了，对吧？是的，我认为这些事情、这类判断确实常常被与家庭成员疏离的人所经历。同样，我认为我们也都有权对自己的家庭关系保持隐私。因此，家庭疏离的一些原因，比如关系中的虐待，并不是那些
like? What are families like rather than what could they be or what should they be? And I imagine a lot of it has to be driven by the fear that people are going to look at you and say, well, you must have been a bad parent or you were a crummy sister and that's why you're not in touch with each other anymore, right? Yeah, I think those are things, those kinds of judgments are experienced, really commonly by people who are estranged from a family member. And as well, I think we are all entitled to privacy about our family relationships as well. So some of those causes of family estrangement, like abuse in a relationship, are not things
你会想告诉你的同事，甚至可能是朋友或伴侣的事情。就像其中一些经历对我们来说是如此私密。并且我们在那种方式上并不欠任何人我们内心最深处的部分，尤其是在没有安全的交往关系来进行那种自我表露的情况下。所以我想到了所有那些我曾交谈过的人，他们在办公室里会说，他们只是编造了一个关于他们在节假日做什么的故事，或者当人们问起他们的家庭以及他们在一起做什么时，他们会准备好一两句排练好的台词。我想我听过太多次了，
that you will want to tell your co-worker about or perhaps friend or partner even. Like some of these experiences are so private to us. And we don't really owe anybody the deepest part of ourselves in that way, especially if that's not a safe relationship to make that kind of disclosure in. So I'm thinking of all those people I've spoken to who will say at the office, they just have a made-up story about what they're doing for the holidays, or they have some kind of rehearsed line or two that they will give when people, ask them about their families and what they're doing together. And I think I've heard that so often
以至于我个人反思发现，实际上我对其他人的家庭生活知之甚少。所以我尽量不做假设。因此，我尽量不对我的学生说，比如说，祝你们在家和家人度过一个愉快的夏天。我尽量保持开放的心态，因为我其实并不知道他们会在哪里，或者他们会和谁一起度过时光。当疏离的家庭成员生病或去世时会发生什么？这种事件如何与悲伤相互交织？我认为这是一个极好的问题，就目前已发表的研究而言，我们还没有完全的答案。但我认为，疏离本身当然可以成为一种悲伤、失落和哀恸的经历，
now that I just reflect personally that I actually know very little about other people's family lives. And so I try not to make assumptions. So I try not to say to my students, you know, have a good summer at home with your families, for example. I try and keep that open mind that I don't actually know where they'll be or who they'll be spending time with. What about when an estranged family member gets sick or dies? How does that occurrence interact with grief? I think that's an excellent question that we don't quite have the answer to in terms of published research yet. But I think certainly estrangement itself can be an experience of grief and loss and bereavement.
因此，当家庭成员去世时，这种感觉可能会加剧，因为当时可能没有办法再得到答案、试图修复或弄清楚发生了什么。但我认为疏离家庭成员的去世对某些人来说也可能是一种解脱，因为那种破坏性关系的痛苦和压力不复存在了。
and so that when a family member dies, that could potentially be heightened as there is no way then to perhaps get answers or attempt repair or find out what happened. But I think a death of an estranged family member can also be a relief to some people as well that the pain and the strain of that damaging relationship is no longer existent.
所以我想，这同样很可能会根据个人的经历而有很大差异。听起来在这个心理科学领域还有相当多的未解之题。我只是在想，你现在在研究什么？你想解答的重大问题是什么？还有很多事情需要去做。我特别对人们寻求支持的经历感兴趣。因此，我与人们交谈了解他们的治疗经历的工作，才是我真正希望关注和继续做下去的。也许还可以缩小范围，我认为那会很有帮助。
So I think, again, that's likely to really vary depending on the individual's experiences. So it sounds like there are quite a few unanswered questions in this area of psychological science. I'm just wondering, what are you working on now? What are the big questions you'd like to answer? There is so much that needs to be done. I'm really interested in people's experience of seeking support in particular. So the work that I've done speaking to people about their therapeutic experiences, that's what I'm really hoping to focus on and continue. And perhaps narrow down as well, I think would be really helpful.
到目前为止，我已经与因各种不同原因而与家庭成员疏离的人交谈过。但我认为也许明确一点会有所帮助，你知道的，当关系因为虐待而破裂时，人们是如何寻求支持的？当关系因为离婚而破裂时，人们是如何经历并寻求支持的？只是在为其中一些事情寻找答案时变得更加狭窄和具体。但我真的认为下一步该做什么，我们现在该做什么，我们如何帮助人们，这对我来说目前感觉非常重要，同时也放大了那些我们听不到的声音。因此，我非常清楚，我所借鉴的大多数研究都是高收入国家样本。我们听到的大多是白人的声音。
So so far I've spoken to people who are estranged from a family member for all sorts of different reasons. But I think perhaps it could be helpful to specify, you know, how do people seek support when a relationship has broken down because of abuse? how do people experience and seek support when relationships have broken down because of divorce and just to get really more narrow and specific in getting answers to some of these things but I really think that what next what do we do now how can we help people that feels really important to me at the moment as well as amplifying those voices that we don't hear So I'm very aware that most of the research I'm drawing on is of samples in countries that are high income. We mostly hear from people who are white.
我们听到的大多是女性的声音。我们对男性疏离经历的了解较少。我认为，疏离研究反映人们经历的多样性是非常重要的。布莱克博士，我想感谢你今天能来参加，并祝你研究顺利。这是一个非常重要的话题。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。谈论这个话题总是令人愉快的。谢谢。您可以了解更多关于布莱克博士和其他心理学家关于家庭疏离的研究。
We hear mostly from women. We hear less about experiences of estrangement by men. There's all sorts of ways, I think, in which it's really important. that estrangement research reflects the diversity of people's experiences. Dr. Blake, I want to thank you for joining me today, and I wish you luck in your research. This is a very important topic. Thank you. Thank you for having me. It's always a pleasure to talk about this topic. Thank you. You can learn more about Dr. Blake's and other psychologists research on family estrangement.
在 APA 杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）4 月刊中。访问 www.APA.org 斜杠 monitor。您可以在我们的网站 www.w.combeckycology.org 上，或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢您听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology 邮箱：at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
In the April issue of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. to www.APA.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology on our website at www.w.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在APA杂志《心理学观察》4月刊中，您可以访问 www.APA.org/monitor。您可以在我们的网站 www.psychology.org 或通过 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及其他播客平台收听《心理学播客》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何建议或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学播客》由李·温厄曼制作，我们的音频编辑是克里斯·孔达扬。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会感谢您的收听。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。